thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo welcome everybody welcome back
to the Saturday morning 3D live stream
and today this Saturday is the first
Saturday that we are getting together
and working on our 3D Community
challenge renders together the moving
meditation 3D challenge this is it this
is stream number one
and it is not too late to join this
challenge if y'all don't know what's
going on
we're doing a 3D challenge we're going
to be combining all of the submissions
together into one Epic martial arts Mega
montage
we got giveaways we got prizes uh Rococo
suits we got kit bash kits we got Wacom
tablets we got uh Da Vinci resolve
Studio Perpetual licenses to give away
um that's just those are the top five
prizes
um we're also giving away some kit bash
exclusive discount codes on every single
one of the streams moving forward
including the stream right here so keep
your ears peeled for them codes uh what
are we doing on this stream well like I
said we're working on our art
we're all working on our art together
for this Challenge and if you don't know
what the challenge is
um everybody gets a project file it's
the same project file but you can pull
any animation you want from the provided
animations they're all like Tai Chi Kung
Fu animations
and we're going to piece them all
together they're all they're going to
flow together it's going to be amazing
and I'm going to be working on my
submission I'm starting my submission
today
um I've been trying to figure out the
right idea a lot of us are trying to
figure out those ideas
um and I'm just getting started so it's
not too late there's a link there's a
Discord Link in the description below if
you want to join us you want to get
working it's not too late
you're gonna go to that Discord it's
gonna take you there and it's gonna give
you the download files it's gonna be the
project files you're gonna get the FAQs
you're gonna get uh the rules all that
stuff you're gonna get access to the
whole Community it's all free
um to help you out got a lot of
questions to be answered
a lot of answers for your questions
what else so I'll be I'm gonna be in
unreal five today
um and I'm just gonna kind of build out
my scene the hardest part is finding a
character uh connecting the it's not
hard to connect the character you just
gotta figure out how to do it
um I'm gonna have to figure out how to
do it myself I know we all are trying to
figure out how to do that
what else
um so I'm gonna be building out the
scene in unreal five
on the stream today
so before we hop in y'all know how we do
this we got some stream sponsors so I'm
gonna throw it to the sponsor real quick
hang tight
um got some good info for you on some
cyber security and then we're gonna be
back and I'm gonna walk you through my
ideas I'm gonna show you how I used AI
art to generate some ideas and where how
that's going to guide me into creating
my art here on the stream today all
right so back in two minutes don't move
your butts see you soon about a year and
a half ago a very good friend of mine
was the target of identity theft his
credit score dropped more than 100
points which prevented him from
refinancing this house which cost them
hundreds of dollars every single month
and he was beyond stressed for the
couple months it took to get everything
straightened out statistically if you're
in a room of 13 people two of those
people will be the target of identity
theft within the year so I am happy to
talk to you guys about Aura the sponsor
of today's video or as an Identity Theft
Protection Service at its core they live
monitor fraud cases provide you with a
VPN for protected browsing help with
password management and offer antivirus
software all packed into one easy to use
application Aura will live monitor the
dark web to look out for your passwords
email addresses and Social Security
numbers and we'll send you a quick alert
to your profile as soon as I signed up I
had 27 unique password and email leaks
and I found it pretty satisfying to go
through them all lock them down and
build up your personal security Fortress
one of the things that helped my buddy
lock down his identity was freezing his
credit that way you have an added layer
of protection requiring verification for
anyone trying to open a line of credit
in your name and Aura can help you do
this efficiently and easily the service
is awesome it does so many things it
actually reaches out to a bunch of
telemarketing companies to remove your
info from their list so that means way
less spam calls Aura is offering y'all a
two-week free trial by clicking the link
in the description below you're not only
helping myself and the channel but are
taking the necessary steps to protect
and lock down your digital identity
yeah yeah boy
um it's actually a really cool service
legit is addicting to lock down all your
stuff and be on top of of everything so
it's pretty sweet definitely click that
link in the description if you guys are
trying to help out the channel here
um and it's helpful for y'all I gotta
say
um
something very special happened on my
actual birthday like a week ago
uh at my birthday dinner
this channel hit a million subscribers
which is freaking nuts oh my God I have
been at it since 2006.
that's like 16 years of this channel my
God I started out during during
um
Grand Theft Auto stunt videos I would
film like my bike stunts in Grand Theft
Auto on my PSP
and edit it in Windows Movie Maker I
posted it on MySpace and I was like my
buddy told me about YouTube
and he was like dude you should post it
on YouTube so I started posting the
Grand Theft Auto stuff videos on YouTube
and then I got to the point where I was
like
um okay what well what can I do from
here you know I started doing tutorials
actually I started and they're on this
channel you can go back
this there's a lot of history on this
channel like I I was on a cruise one
time and I logged into a public computer
and I stayed logged into that public
computer when I was like a kid and they
they wiped all my videos they cleared
everything I had a video that was like
at a million views it was like of a 3D
mini gun just displaying a minigun that
I made in Cinema 4D
and uh the channel got wiped and I was
like man this gives me an opportunity to
start fresh and start new and and and
really make the things on this channel
the best they can be something I started
doing tutorials that you can watch now
on this channel if you go way back uh
After Effects tutorials
um and whatnot and uh started doing
short films and started doing short
films for different video games like the
Sleeping Dogs video uh cardboard Warfare
was before that
um yeah and then got into like
Wolfenstein Dead Island doing videos for
their games
and then I took a six year Hiatus six
years because I was at Rocket Jump and
then I went to Corridor and I was at
three years at each of them and and you
all probably know at this point I I left
Corridor to come back here to work on my
channel and to build it back up and when
I came back it was at like 350 000
subscribers about a year and a half ago
maybe two years ago
and now we're in a million my goodness
thank you all so much for
for for hanging out with me and doing
this with me like every single week it's
been amazing we've done such cool stuff
together and we're still doing cool
stuff we're doing this challenge right
now
and we're doing it together that's the
best part as we're doing this together
so thank you guys thank you everyone so
much for
for supporting me over the years and
and watching my videos and being here
for a long long time so thank you let's
get into the art shall we let's get into
the art
all right
so
this is my pure ref
erence board right
this is the art that I'm using to guide
my art
in Unreal Engine 5.
um along and I'll talk about this a
little bit so here's my idea here's the
idea right I want to have a character in
some sort of like
blank space like a lab of some sort
you know
um sitting in a chair
in the middle of the room
and they're strapped up to like VR stuff
almost right
kind of like this
and
it's a FIBA old man
definitely a feeble old man
and
you know this is another great example
this is from Ash this is Ash Thorpe one
of my favorite oh my God one of my
favorite 3D artists so good
and they're strapped up to this right
and they sit up out of their chair
and they have all these wires hanging
from their head right
and they
whereas they raised their arms into the
starting pose that y'all are very
familiar with
the the room around them like flickers
and blinks
and transports them digitally transports
them like I like the Matrix to a rooftop
there's a place called The Kowloon
walled City and I think they tore it
down in 95 it was in Hong Kong and it
was the most densely packed place in the
world at the time I believe
it was basically some slums it was some
slums and uh
but the Vibes were off the charts
and
that's kind of what that's the
environment that I want to build I'm
kind of doing two environments yes I
know as last challenge I was like
I'm biting off more than I can chew on
the last challenge oh no I'm not gonna
do it again
I have a plan for that first and
foremost I gotta focus on what's
important and that is justifying every
single one of these renders that are
going to come before this one okay or
come after this one so the idea is that
like this character has this headset and
then the room will Flicker and blink and
turn into an environment
and I'm gonna focus on this scene first
because that is what's needed to kind of
pass the ball off to all the other
renders in the montages
and then when it comes time for me to
create an environment because I do want
to create an environment of knit yeah an
environment of my own
I'm gonna base it off this kind of
rooftop scene I think it'll be pretty
darn simple I'll probably get some kit
bash buildings
pop them into the background like you
see here get this kind of early morning
foggy light
and just make a pretty simple foreground
with some puddles
on a rooftop with some like uh
you know some trash some bottles some
radar dishes some antennas that kind of
stuff
and beyond that I'm just gonna mess with
some cloth physics I think I'm gonna do
it in c4d I'm gonna Sim it in c4d
because they got their new claw system
looking real nice and then I'm gonna
bring that back into Unreal Engine I'm
finishing everything in Unreal Engine
because I'm trying to put my points in
an Unreal Engine it's an awesome program
I love it and I love being able to just
iterate quickly and make really cool
scenes
from from my brain to the screen as
quick as possible
um
so thanks again everybody we got 1100
people in here I better start making
some art huh
I'm gonna preface this for y'all right
now I'm prefacing this for you guys
I kind of have a direction I kind of
have a direction you heard me talk it
out
but
we'll see we're in it y'all this ain't a
pop this isn't this isn't a polished
tutorial I'm gonna be making mistakes
left and right but I'm gonna be learning
through my failures I will learn
and that's how we do it on this channel
we gotta learn and we gotta grow and
we're doing it together y'all are
working on your scenes I'm working on my
scene if you guys are in the chat right
now and you're working on your
submission give me a thumbs up
I want to see it
I want to see them thumbs y'all
also I don't know if y'all notice but
maybe notice we got a new microphone set
up
deity mics shout out to deity
microphones
this is the is the sister company of
aperture who makes the lights big fan of
them
um we got a little shotgun mic right up
in here so hopefully it's sounding good
also we got we got our little our buddy
our little buddy
we got the Stream producer himself right
up here so
I'm gonna say hello hello surprise what
a new cool feature that I can talk to
you guys directly hello yeah heck yeah
so soda might be popping in from time to
time
saying hello sorry for calling you a
little buddy
I will never forgive you how could you
do this to me I'm driving now but look
at you it's like a a little buddy just
up here you know chilling out no friend
yeah
all right all right let's get back to it
we got thumbs
we got a lot of thumbs y'all
oh thumbs down Ed's why
why my friend
I believe in you some of you are like oh
can I can I join this challenge or not
can I sorry I messed that up let me
restart some of you guys are like
oh I can't join the challenge because
I'm not good enough
you know what that is some Malarkey okay
y'all can do it people learned how to
use blender for these challenges and
they were in the montages
so this is the perfect time to learn
what are you guys talking about if you
if you have any interest in learning 3D
literally this is the time to do it
download freaking blender right now
download Unreal Engine right now
hop in it's so much fun
um okay
I'm getting my chair and we're doing
this
oh
all righty
whoo
I did it all right that was the intro we
got the brand segment in
we got the talking points we got the
announcements I think I can relax now
[Music]
these streams are always like
always stressful at first at first
they're always stressful
I'm always nervous beforehand you know
it's like anytime I was gonna run the
mile
uh in middle school every Friday we had
to run the mile oh my God I was so
anxious and so stressed out every Friday
hmm
but as soon as I ran it was on and like
afterwards is the best so
that's why I'm always getting pizza
after these dang streams
I'm gonna move my prf board over to the
right side I might bring it in from time
to time
um if I need to really talk something
out but here yeah here's what I'm
specifically trying to do so right now I
kind of have this set up
um I would love to get a roof going I
think building out a roof would be sweet
so that's probably on my list
um this is the Donald Glover this is
America music video
I'm using this for reference
um nice Warehouse scene and it reminded
me of inception I was like weren't they
tapping in in like a warehouse as well
so I think it'd be cooler to build out
like a a mix between a warehouse and a
room like this
so
maybe the dolly Inn starts on something
looking like this or rather like this
the dolly in starts here and when we get
in it's like more produced right it's
kind of like a
more of a look like this
and this is another example of like um
this is Chemical Brothers music video if
you've never seen this music video oh my
God
this is one of the best music videos of
all time
um but I love this environment this
environment might be the ideal perfect
environment because it's the right size
I love these hanging lights up here so I
might try and go to like
make make some moves in this direction
um
and then
kind of fill it out and make mix these
kind of two Vibes here
some way
somehow
let's begin
all right
so I got this psych it's called a psych
this thing right here is called a psych
it is spelled
like that
cuic Psych
and it is used to kind of get that
infinite background kind of feel usually
they're not reflective like mine usually
they're just matte
if I hop into my camera
right click oh you see it's not
available and I think that's a bug
it's because I changed my layout and
when I change it back it doesn't do it
so you need to find the actual camera
you can hit G to show and hide your
stuff
we'll pilot it
we can also hit the Cinematic viewport
and I will need to open up my actual
sequence so we'll open the content
drawer
I'll go to my sequences
and we'll open up
the sequence here
it's not doing anything it's not in the
camera got a quick little camera
and then we're in okay
all right I'm gonna move my sequencer
over
to the other screen
awesome
and I also have my materials so let's go
to materials I made some master
materials
um we have a basic material instance I
can adjust this here the roughness you
can just take the specular down to zero
and that kind of gives you more of that
Infinite Space look the lighting is
what's
making it look not infinite right now it
needs to be more evenly lit across every
single area of this thing
um
but
where do I start so many places to start
I'm gonna go back to my default view
here
okay I think
first I'm going to try and get to that
80 Mark by the end of the Stream
that's my goal
this is just in a room I made this with
a bunch of walls that come with the uh
starter content
right so you have your let's see your
starter content architecture and you got
all your walls and stuff so that's what
I'm using
and I could even turn off the the
lighting here let's see I can turn off
my directional light
and inside we have our scene so that's
how I'm doing that
Let's see we can drop this below the
floor
I'm doing small little things that don't
really matter at this point I need to
I need to shape up
you can hide this floor too
and delete it
all right
let's see about building out that
warehouse
well we got some Z fighting going on
uh I see
it's just because this texture is this
it's overlaying on that as well
um okay
let's go ahead and hide our Psych
we have our room here it's all grouped
Ctrl shift G should ungroup it all
and I'm just going to open this up
a little bit wider
and I'm going to grab all these walls
actually
and open this up
I'm just eyeballing it
spacebar will toggle between your
position rotation and scale gizmos
foreign
we got our character let's see what it
looks like in our camera
oh we need to go a little further
and we can pin that camera
by finding it in our outliner on the
right here
selecting it and just hitting this
little little pin
that way we know how far we gotta go
now I might mention this
one more time
but them Kit bash discount codes all
right I you know we talked about them
and we're gonna have one per stream
but today's exclusive
stream exclusive kit bash code if y'all
trying to get some kit Bash
tools if you don't know if you know what
kid bash is they make a bunch of like
themed
kits
um
of different skyscrapers buildings props
with a whole bunch of different themes
they're super cool we got a link in the
description kitbash3d.com
and we oh we got kit bash in that house
too what's up yo
so y'all if y'all trying to get them Kit
bash kits
we got you a 20 off
for this stream only
if you use the code moving20
[Music]
moving 20.
they're definitely going to help you
build out your scene I know that they
are also one of the sponsors for the
challenge as well
um
so the top 100 artists making it into
the top 100 Montage all get a kid back
kiss a kit bat
goodness a kid a kit bash 3D kit of
their choice
so that's a hundred kits out to all top
100 artists one of one each of your of
their choice and the top five artists
get three kits of their choice
heck yeah
I'll open that message for y'all
feel free to feel free to use it feel
free to take advantage
um
let's see all right let's get this roof
up
we're gonna get all these up I'm gonna
shift click all this stuff group it and
move it all up at once
Ctrl G Will Group
let's get that roof up there and then
let's go ahead and shift click all these
guys
I made it out of six panels
where are you there you are space bar
again we'll cycle between
cycle between your position rotation and
scaled gizmos and we'll take our lights
and got some lights in here if you hit G
that's going to show and hide all your
stuff all right so let's take these
lights shift click all these guys
get rid of that one I don't know why
that one's being weird shift click all
these actually I know why
because should be because the light is
set to
these lights are set to stationary they
should all be set to movable
that way we get that real-time feedback
you know to bake any lighting none of
that nonsense I ain't trying to bake
lighting today
let's grab all these
wreck lights
we can move them up
very nice and we can
move them Let's see we can duplicate
by holding Alt
yeah we'll get some there and we'll hold
alt and we'll get some
over here
and I'm gonna go ahead and
locate these out
to the back of the room as well
I'm holding right click and I'm using
w-a-s-n-d just like you're in a first
person shooter to move around
scene
I think it's the best way to navigate a
3D scene and I wish every program would
adopt this method because it's it's so
easy it's the best I know the only other
program I know that does this
um granted I haven't used every single
program in the world so I'm sure there
might be more but I know Rococo Studio
um
allows you to navigate like that as well
we can take all those lights if you want
and we can
make sure they're in
jumping in real quick to say you can do
it in blender too but it doesn't have a
hotkey by default so if you go to view
and then I think it's
fly or what navigation I don't remember
one which one if you give it a hotkey
you can do it in blender as well
heck yeah
do you use it
no not much only to like move my camera
like my rendering camera that's it yeah
yeah I love it navigating this way is
great
all right so
all right we ever seen it's generally
kind of framed up we have our warehouse
so what we can do
is
think about I want to think about how
this is going to be shown like how much
we're gonna see because I don't want to
fill out anything that we're not really
going to see and if I had a better
direction of a very specific clear
direction of where I was going with this
I would have that answer and I should
have that it's just
you know things are busy y'all I'm I'm
saying it I'm gonna say it
ain't no excuse gotta run it through I
gotta run this channel somehow right
so there's a lot of work to be done on
the channel I wish I had all the time to
spend on the art I'd be a little further
ahead
um but it's okay we're gonna get there
we are gonna get there
so if you can have a clear idea of where
you want to go
um I'm trying to figure out how I'm
gonna blend this kind of setup
right this kind of setup
without all the stuff because I would
take eons with this kind of setup
and I think the best way to do it is
like
with a roof I think no matter what it's
gonna there's gonna be a roof like this
so let me just get into creating
a roof I'll start there
and then we can figure out what else is
going to be seen so this is a great
example
of a roof
this is also another really good example
of
an industrial style roof here is another
great example of an industrial style
roof
this is America music video once again
this is a great example of an industrial
style roof so I think it's just a lot of
blocks pillars concrete
that kind of stuff and
I think I got the perfect thing for that
because I have a bunch of concrete
materials and textures
and it looks like there's rows of like
support beams going across so
I think I'm gonna try and block some of
that stuff in and then get some pipes
running along with some lights hanging
and see how that Vibe feels I think it
could look pretty sweet
so
let me get out of the camera let me set
my roof up here and then I can lower it
as needed right
so there's a number of ways we can do
this we can hop into quixel Bridge top
left up here we can hop in and we can
start pulling our assets here 3D assets
um we can go for industrial we can go
for construction
and probably somewhere
in here we will find
some things that will help us
um
these are all really tiny I know that
there's like some good concrete stuff
Hardware mining Railway let's see
Hardware
that's like stuff these bolts are not
bolts these aren't bolts these are pipes
these pipes are going to be real Handy
I know we'll need some of those so what
I'll do is actually I'll go through and
I'll start favoriting things and before
I favorite things I'll make sure my
favorites are clear
so I'll go to my 3D assets and make sure
all
no no
no because I need those this is
we built a couple streams ago
um this is great I'm just gonna bring
some of these in because these are
totally
totally what we need
that's why I love favoriteing stuff
BD assets
and let's hit up dark heroes Super Chat
here while I transfer these items over
let me get them let me get that transfer
going first I want to download these
things
download download download download
yep
I want to download them nanites
and hit download all right dark hero you
got a question
for our request of some sort or
something let me turn up this
uh quick question when opening the
unreal template the camera isn't in the
scene do I need to add a new one or no
okay the camera should be in the scene
um
I'm trying to remember what I had to do
to get the camera
or show the camera because I think I'm
think I'm understanding what you're
talking about
um
I think a couple people might have that
question as well so what I can do is
actually
let me just open up
let's see here
let's open up the starter file and see
what we can see project files
Unreal Engine
I got you guys
okay
so if I just open this up
what do you see
all right this is what I see a camera
here
so if you're not seeing that camera then
that's interesting we can right click it
and pilot it what you're not seeing is a
character the standard mannequin this
standard mannequin is here it's just not
linked to a static mesh so that is
that's on me y'all I take full
responsibility for this I set this
project file up myself so you just got
to go to mesh and you got to drop that
mannequin into the the static mesh on
the mannequin and and there you go and
if you open up your sequence
what up
you should have your scene all right
here
um
so you don't see the camera that's
interesting because my camera is right
here at maybe you're in like a different
version or something
um
yeah I know that could be the case
foreign
but yeah I don't know like
the the Discord is great for that
because you can get answers to a bunch
of questions
um
you know
hit up that Discord hit up that
community
I'm sure you got questions they got
answers
we're all figuring it out together but
you should be seeing this
should be seeing this
uh Hey easy Sonic's great great great
suggestion 90 of the unreal issues are
fixed with updating unreal it's the
latest version try that first I am on
the latest version of unreal so
maybe consider
switch into that latest version
all right
Let Us return
where are you at
yes we will save okay back in
all right so we want them pillars and
stuff I think we got them from
pixel so I made a mega scans folder
surfaces oh no no no no no that did not
happen yet because we still need
to
what
not downloaded
crazy
well download Michelle
are we allowed to rotate move the
character rig
ah
read the FAQs read the rules
the rules no you cannot
you cannot move the character around the
scene
you can't rotate them around the scene
you know why
because at the beginning of this live
stream
there was a it's also in the
announcement video
there was a video showing a couple
different test animations test scenes
and it cuts very seamlessly between them
the only reason it's cutting seamlessly
between them is because you don't move
the character you don't rotate the
character around they all start like
this
right they all start like this
and they should all end like this if you
start moving your character around it's
gonna it's not gonna make the Montage
it's gonna be cut from the Montage so do
not get banished
from these montages y'all
follow them rules
and please read them carefully
moderators only have so much moderator
juice
because once their moderator meter is
empty who knows what
um
cyber what about something them holding
something in their hands
read the FAQs read the rules read the
previously asked questions
you just go there and read it
are you the rules
the rules nfaq
ready
okay let's export this stuff export to
nanite
I want to export all of these mugs to
nanite so I'm just going to hit add
and they should populate into our scene
automatically
if we close this then we should have oh
yeah all these like
pillars and stuff
yes it needs to compute
yeah y'all don't want to see that
moderator
meters on empty
that is not a good site
yes
this is what I need
this is what I need
bringing in all the goods because this
is what I need
bring it in all them Goods this is what
I need
yes yes
all right
uh
get out don't want to see you anymore
tired of you
okay
so I am just gonna
get these pillars up here
this one's looking the chunkiest of them
all but we can of course scale them
and all that good stuff
um I am going to
hold alt move this
rotate it we can also do this with uh
with the texture
probably a lot
easier on your a lot easier on your
system
with a texture
or a Shader rather
a material perhaps there's the right
terminology
see if we can get to 80 y'all that's
what I'm trying to do trying to get to
80 percent
and it's going to be a good day if I can
get to 80 percent
I want to get this roof done okay so we
got some sort of support beams up here
all right let's bring these guys up next
we'll scale it yes yes sir
let's go chunk with it I want to chunk
it up boom
a little beefier
holding Alt
move this stuff over
wonderful
that is amazing and then we have a third
row I'm gonna go
and chunk it up
and we can just duplicate from here
we also want to make sure our lights
are in the right spot
I want that concrete
jungle kind of vibe that is what I'm
going for let's take these Ctrl G
am I lying to you guys
control shift Control Alt control God
group is Control G
I wasn't lying
Ctrl shift G will
hi
oh it's because my keep it's because my
keyboard
my control button
has a hard time
these days
hmm
yeah okay now that works that works
I'm gonna delete a couple of these
and uh regroup these guys I think if I
do I have to select them all again
select them all again don't I group
what the heck
Ctrl shift G I think you have to hit
Ctrl shift G again
all right there we go
and I just want to scale it up
sweet
all right
and let's go ahead and grab these
Ctrl G to group we'll grab these Ctrl G
to group now we have our like three main
pillars right we'll put this dark one we
can always adjust it and make it
brighter but I'll put this dark one like
in the back in the corner and then
I'll bring these guys out
hitting G will show and hide our lights
so
kind of position them in between
these lights
like so
and it's not perfect but we will get it
there I don't think we need to do any
more tweaking Beyond this as much as I
love tweaking and I want to get to the
tweaking point
we should move on
now we have pillars to talk about
we can add some pillars coming from the
top here
we can add some pillars and pipes coming
from the top here
um
yeah this metal
kind of scaffolding let's see what else
kit bash hat not kit Bash
quixel let's see what else quixel has
um Brandon what's up thank you for the
Super Chat
two dollar for 50 character
what are you talking about
I don't know what you're talking about
son
but thank you for that Super Chat I
appreciate you very much
um
um let's see let's hit up
quixel Bridge once again
and let's find some metal
railing stuff 3D Assets Now if you guys
are using Unreal Engine
all of this
all these beautiful
um quixel assets come for free with
Unreal Engine okay but if you're using
anything other than Unreal Engine you
got to pay for them and I think it's
like 20 bucks a month I think
is what it is
so let's hit up
well you know what they have collections
um arcviz potentially 3D
uh is this where is this where I am
uh it's either environment or Essentials
let's try environment
industrial abandoned Factory this is
what I'm looking for
yes yes
these things these two right here let's
heart these guys I always like the heart
the assets that I'm using because I want
to keep it all in one place I don't have
to search through this whole thing again
you know what I'm saying
um
is that really it huh
if you click on one of them you can go
to a similar
oh the only similar one is is this one
it's brother
well
nonetheless Let's uh let's download
these
nanite quality
and let's also see what happens if we
search for oh let's go into the mines
let's dip oh wait Warehouse though
a lot of the same
assets
wait a second
I think I just realized something
I've been playing this game straight and
it's the best game ever I love it oh
these lights these fluorescent ceiling
lamps
oh exactly what I need
download them nanite quality anyway
this is so dumb by the way but
I've been playing this game straight
it's the best game ever it is a master
class on 3D environments and lighting oh
my goodness
please download this game if you can
and I just recognized this asset right
here this box this plastic crate I think
is in the game
I think is in the game
I went through and I took a bunch of
screenshots
of different environments as you can
kind of tell by my background
so there's kind of there's potential for
light stray spoilers potentially I'm
going to add these to the scene
amazing I'm also going to add those uh
those pillars in a second but let's see
if we got anything else
oh these single point lights are pretty
good
this cable this power cable
oh man maybe this is the chair that
they're on
why not let's give it a shot
even if it's just standing in scratched
metal pull yes
let's get these
and download them
brand Doom I agree stray Game of the
Year Game of the Year for me at least
my God
I'm on my third playthrough
trying to go for the speed run
it's so much fun oh it's so good
all right what other assets here I don't
want to like pack out this Warehouse I'm
just looking for a ceiling
I'm going for some subtleness here
uh um this modular beam pack
could be handy let's go ahead and pull
this
all right
I see Ness I'm a hundred percent down
uh you're saying I'm reading this as
stray is better than Eldon ring but you
put Eldon mid I don't know what Eldon
mid is but
I maybe you're not saying that but I
think stray is better than Ellen ring
for sure
it's a very different game
don't get me wrong
uh rayanch will new non-clipping rigs
come yes they are in the works
um
we have seen y'all's requests for that
non-clipping we are doing our best to
get him out to you you are welcome
to
fix any clipping issues that work for
your character
um
as long as you're not changing the start
and end pose
um then you're able to do that
because maybe you're trying to have the
Hulk be your main character and all of
this CL like the whole thing clips
so just know that
what we're providing you all the
animations we're providing are like the
base level if you change it too much
it's not going to be the move anymore
and it's going to look weird so you
really gotta take that very carefully be
very careful with that but yes we are
working on non-clipping
animations and hope to be out pretty
soon
all right let's add these modular pipes
I'm just building out my assets here
guys
um let's go ahead and
download these pipes
foreign
modular pipes there's a
looks like there was like a pack for
this okay yeah they only have these few
six six three visuals what is up glad
you're here checking out the Stream
we got steady 1300 people in the chat
thank you all so much for joining me and
hanging out we're creating art today
we're making a cool like
little Warehouse scene
something simple something simple like
this we're working on the roof right now
uh going for something like this
something like this
is what we're going for
okay let's add
these pipes are added I believe
I think we need to add
these guys
and do we have oh we got a Super Chat
zykobon what is up
uh love from Malaysia heck yeah
um you and the quarter crew inspire a
lot of three artists and VFX here
let's go absolutely uh keep it up keep
it up keep working keep growing I'm glad
to help you all and
um offer any little bit of inspiration I
can I'm just trying to do my thing
create some cool stuff
so I'm glad that uh I'm glad that you're
doing the same I hope to come down to
Malaysia one day one of my very best
friends is Malaysian and uh we we gotta
plan a Malaysia trip that is a hundred
percent
um is there an age limit for the
competitions no there's no age limit for
the competitions
Horizon forbidden West I actually just
started Horizon zero Dawn because I
missed it
so I'm hoping to hoping to get through
it it's a big game y'all
all right there was um there was some
stuff that I did not download that is in
our favorites I know I'm missing
something is those beams
it was those beams
easy Sonics what's going on
DreamWorks released its render engine as
open source you should give it a try huh
interesting
Soto have you heard anything about that
I just read it yesterday I don't know if
they already released it or they were
gonna release it but it seems super
interesting for like rendering with
multiple computers at the same time even
on viewport so like if you have five
computers you can get a super fast
preview and things like that pretty
interesting
heck yeah and I assume it's for every
program like unreal and c4d blender
um this is a bit technical they have a
Hydra that I get so at least it's gonna
work with everything that works with USD
Universal scene description so it should
get a lot of support eventually
thanks for that info and thank you for
that Super Chat
shout outs to ya
easy Sonics good stuff
um all right all right oh I remember we
had there was a tip on the other stream
I don't know why this is happening at
this point it shouldn't be but it was
like my um my render or my textures
the the streaming pool texture streaming
pool we need to up that so I think it
was like r dot
dreaming
streaming pool
God dang does everyone does anyone
remember
uh
streaming
was it this nanite streaming streaming
pool size
1000 I might destroy this whole thing
right now
uh okay
so quick tip for you
if you hit the output log
you can see what's going on
all right I want to reset that back to
default so if I go to r dot and I know
this is super small but if you go to r
dot nanite
well nanite streaming pool
where are you streaming
pool
this one I want to reset it back to it
to its default if you hit question mark
it'll tell you what's good with it so
our name is a read-only it's read only
size of stream pull in megabytes does
not include memory use for Pages r.net
streaming pool size 512.
last set by me
so 512 is default I guess
right now
streaming pool tab and then 512.
um
r dot streaming pool size 8000 thank you
Jr
Mark read the FAQs
you have to reset my scene
I don't know anyway I'm moving on
oh that's some weird weirdness going on
here
it probably has to do with
these guys not being entirely up in the
wall
cool
all right lots of cool things to add in
we got our concrete beams right we got
those we got some pillars we got them in
ceiling lamps these
totally all right totally if we can get
some like tungsten
nasty old
bulbs
yeah that's what we need
this is a ceiling lamp in here what is
this
this is this is how we want to light our
scene with these guys
yep
yep that's gonna look really really nice
kind of what's going on here right
and it's kind of what we have a little
bit even in this AI art I use
mid-journey for these this was
mid-journey
these guys were mid-journey
pretty sweet pretty cool program
um
yeah kind of like that Vibe here with
these lights
this is literally those lights are here
same here
same here
so let's set up these lights yeah
um we could do
a number of things all right so if we go
to window
uh Place actors window that's gonna have
all of our stuff that we can drop into
our scene
the lights
all right so I know I know how to do
this let's grab a cylinder shall we
let's rotate it 90.
and let's go ahead and
scale it down
stretch it out
and get it in place
generally in place
uh you can use the middle Mouse wheel or
top right up here change this number and
that's going to lower your camera
sensitivity
and I feel like these guys are a little
a little big
so I'm going to scale them down just a
little bit more
foreign come on now
yeah just like that
holding alt to duplicate
let's make a material
and let's make an emissive material all
right so let's make a master material
um I kind of already did it though
let's see
basic material too I could be more
organized on this I'm just kind of
messing around so
we have an emissive material yeah all
right so let me let me just show y'all
from scratch we got what red
Ren you scoundrel you little skip skip
a Hootie
I don't know why I'm saying these things
what's up Ren
dang man
sir render in the house what are you
doing son what time is it it's almost
noon are you still in bed
what games are you playing right now Ren
you try don't don't come over here
and get whipped in Smash Bros because I
don't have it set up all right we can't
do that we can't do that right now
for those of you who don't know
freaking Ren
we were doing I forget what it was like
we were doing like we were live judging
something or no no we did a stream
together we were like modeling and
texturing a one-wheel together and
animating it right and um
I challenged Ren to come over to my
house to drive to my house
and get beat
live on stream in Smash Bros of course
and uh he came over he couldn't he
couldn't withstand the the pressure
of of the the idea that someone was
calling him out saying he was just gonna
get whipped
um he came over
you know we traded we traded matches
okay we traded matches but he pulled the
match
where he won and he put it into his
Dynamic machines render that he did like
a year ago
good freaking times Ren glad you're here
dude
hope you hope your hand is okay
all right
we're making a mess of materials an
Unreal Engine Wren let me show you how
easy it is
uh right click make a master material
where is it Master material Master
material
emissive
you know what I'm gonna rename this
because it's just the master material if
I hit if I hold three and and left click
it's going to make a color a solid we'll
plug that into base color I wonder if
you right click and promote it to a
parameter it'll do that thing for you
I'm right clicking all of these
parameters specular roughness and I'm
just promoting them to parameters you
don't have to worry about
typing in anything in you just right
click and promote
now a Miss of color
I want to promote that to a parameter
I also want to want to control its
intensity all right so let's say the
emissive color is
Orange
let's say the emissive color
is orange
great but how do we crank it all right
that's with a multiply node so a holding
M and left click will make a multiply if
you hold s and click you make a scalar
parameter this is going to be called
emissive intensity
that goes in a b this goes into a
honestly the order doesn't matter
because it's multiply and we pipe that
into emissive and when your emissive is
at zero of course you're going to have
no power one will be default
a million
all right
we want that tungsten color all right so
I wonder
I'm sure there's a way to do this
accurately
I'm sure
but I know it's like a greenish
off-white
nasty kind of color
somewhere in this range I don't know
question mark
or maybe we can just really go green
with it you know like
like mint like denting ice
color
all right and
oh to go even a step further I'm gonna
do something crazy all right I'm I don't
need to be doing this
I don't need to be doing this but let's
let's take it a step at a time all right
emissive this is our massive material
we're going to duplicate it or I'm sorry
we're gonna make a material instance by
right clicking click material instance
and if you apply this to these tubes
they're gonna glow They're Gonna Shine
they're gonna make everything look fine
and we're going to hide these lights
and have everything be lit
from
this light source and you know what
we'll make this even better if we add
some
height fog exponential height fog
and we set it to like 0.05
and then we like
we go to the
scroll down and we click volumetric fog
that looks awful
I'm gonna tell you right now the Albedo
we should take to Black I think
text or streaming pool
again
interesting
maybe it's a thing where I need to like
maybe emissives have trouble all right
so here's what I'll do let's uh here's
what I was really gonna do I wasn't
gonna actually light the scene with
these I was gonna cheat it and then just
use a some area lights
because I think that'll be a bit more
accurate lighting wise
um dude this looks like a spa
right now
um
you've been lighting everything should
be movable though nothing should be like
baked
movable
um
anyway I can take the emissive intensity
down
so this is in our
material instance I'll take that
emissive intensity down to like
one
right
and then what we can do is actually grab
a
H where are you a rectangular light
and have this kind of be the the True
Light Source
[Music]
because again it'll just be a bit more
accurate and then
um let's go ahead
and make sure our width and height is
correct
and you see this like
it almost looks like it has a square
within a square or a rectangle within a
rectangle
what we can do
is those are those are the barn doors
and that's exactly what this thing has
you can see how the light isn't coming
up to the ceiling
it's being directed down to the ground
so
I'm gonna do the same thing with with
this light if we turn off the submissive
right
we take the intensity to zero
and we look at the ground and we see how
much light is hitting the ground we can
bring the barn doors in we can angle
them in
and we can angle the length too
right so now it's just like a light
blasting down like that but if we want
to actually match what we're seeing we
can bring it up
like this and open it
like that and that is kind of
replicating what this light is doing
and we can change the
color profile
the light color to that kind of greenish
tungsten
look
and we can move this up
like that
something like that and then we can take
those bulbs back and just give them like
0.5 intensity just enough to Glow what I
was going to do the step that I was
going to go above and beyond with
who knows if this is necessary but if
you look at a light it's not going to be
just pure white they're actually
um oh you're right thank you Soto it is
fluorescent it's not tungsten tungsten
is
4 200 Kelvin
um fluorescent that's what I meant to
say thank you
um
so if you look at this light it's not
just a pure bulb there's actually a
brighter core and it falls off to a
less bright outer area
if that makes any sense and then also
you can get real nice with it and put
some dead bugs up in there but that's a
detail that No One's Gonna See
but I will try this one because I'm
curious
and I think I'm gonna do it with a
fernel
fresnel
I think this is how it's done I've never
messed with this uh
yeah I've never messed with this node
before
I think the best way to test materials
based off of a channel I'm watching
called prismatica Dev prismatica devs I
think it's prismatica Dev
he always says put whatever you're
trying to test in the base color
let's turn off
this intensity and there you go you see
what it's doing it's bright on the
outside and it's dark on the inside and
we kind of want the opposite right so
if we do a 1 minus node
that'll essentially invert what's
happening
so it's white here and dark here and I'm
wondering like
if I start plugging numbers into this
what will happen so
Expo tin if I set this to one it looks
default if I set it to two
three it looks like
it looks like the white is being pushed
out the black is being pushed away so if
I set it to one
or 0.5
that's kind of I guess what I want it to
look like
um if you hit one
that will make a uh a consonant and it's
not a parameter we don't want to adjust
this we don't think we need to adjust
this
so I can type 0.5 into here but since
I've never done this before I'm going to
leave it as a parameter I might want to
adjust this
um from here it looks like that is what
I want it to look like so
does that mean we have to multiply
this
old deal
see I get so sidetracked this is fun
with this
into a missive color we can get that out
of
base color
and if we turn on our our glow
I think that totally works
yeah that totally works
now maybe you could have a brighter base
color that way it's like the color of
the lamp when it's turned off
and it just sounds like pure black I
don't know let's see if we can get the
dramatic effect first
right we go for the most dramatic and
see if we get it working and then we can
work in from there so maybe
if I set this to zero
foreign
yes okay so that that updates I'm gonna
just mess with this on the screen off to
the side here and see what happens
0.02
yeah you kind of get it
kind of get it there
and then the base color
I don't know
like a yell like a nasty tinted yellow
[Music]
uh okay so but that's going
that doesn't work face color doesn't
show through
I think I just need
hmm
I'm so close to giving up right now
because this doesn't matter it's such a
small detail
let's get back to building the scene God
dang it
[Music]
[Music]
we can group this light
with this little fluorescent bulb I'll
grab these and we'll hit Ctrl G
put that into a folder and call this uh
fluorescent
[Music]
let's see fluorescent
White
Lab Studios oh that's nice I like that
all right
so you have the fluorescent details
6400 Kelvin
use RGB you have RGB code for me thank
you
let's see all right 252 247.
five
that's fluorescent
that's just like white
basically huh
foreign
that's so bright
so we'll have to definitely take that
down
and we'll grab our light
our rec light Ctrl shift G to ungroup
and you said the Kelvin
temperature is six
e 400.
all right
let's get rid of our fog
and we can turn down the intensity of
this light
a bit intense
foreign
ly scale it or we can double them up
like this
yep and then we can control G those guys
and move them around our scene all right
cool
middle Mouse wheel to adjust your camera
speed
or is that toggle up on the right side
is telling you to check your phone
what
why
why
the video this is a video of Ren in bed
no why
ah Rin this is Ren right now
Ren this is what you you asked for it
dude they're gonna see your bony little
feet your shrimpy little chicken toes
you happy rent are you happy
Love You Ren
a little shrimpy chicken feet
oh Good Times let's duplicate some
lights
yeah
looking good
why are these guys going all
immovable on me they should be movable
boom boom boom
grab these
push them back bring them up
well they kind of want to be in the
scene too
and we'll probably have to adjust the
the radius
of the barn doors on those back ones
because it's a little intense
get rid of those we can grab all of
these guys all these rectangle lights
and kind of bring them down just a touch
and we can open up our sequencer to see
what our camera is looking like
very dark alright so we can grab our
camera
and adjust the exposure so what I'm
doing here
I grab the camera
here on the right side if we look for uh
exposure
you can see I've set it to manual and
the compensation is set to 12.
15 could be nice
and let's get that those barn doors off
the back wall not looking too hot
right now
[Music]
let's see all right so I wanna I wanna
select
all of these
at once
all of these guys
you should be able to adjust the Barn
Door length
on all of them
that's just zero
let's look at this reference here that
light doesn't look like it's doing too
much they're definitely hitting this
wall with a bunch of lights off screen
I think they're more just lighting the
scene with other lights and then just
using these as
as filler so they may not actually be
lighting the scene with those
which would mean I would kind of split
the difference here I would take off all
of these rectangle lights as an example
right we get rid of all those
we definitely don't want to light the
scene with
with this emissive material because
well you know to be honest I don't know
the answer
but
let's see where are you
uh emissive instance if I just
we crank it
this is what it looks like we try and
light it with these bulbs only
it doesn't look good
we just want enough
so that they're there you know
and then we can go back to
just the normal Lighting in the room
[Music]
which again doesn't look right but we'll
get there we'll get there
um what else do we need to add we need
to add some support beams so we can do
this with the concrete let's try and get
a floor looking good this floor is not
A vibe right now
um
let's go to Mega scans surfaces
cracked concrete floor let's pull that
out and see what it looks like
looks like some mud
it would be nice to have a blue tint on
it we open up that
master or that uh material instance we
can go to Albedo tint
we can tint it bluish
interesting interesting
see I have scratched metal pole rusty
metal rusty metal rusty metal
I also have my materials My Endless
concrete
materials
let's see what this floor looks like
it's not bad is it reflective
we want that nice Reflections off the
floor see this is a semi-reflective
floor here
reflection on the floor here
I can't really see it too much on this
one
obvious on this one
but a little reflection goes a long way
foreign
so what I'm doing right now is I'm
falling into the Trap of adding details
I'm trying to get it locked in perfectly
and I don't I don't need to be doing
that right now I need to get again as
quickly to the 80 Mark as possible
it's very easy to get sidetracked as you
can see
and it's I think it's it's definitely
difficult doing it live as well where
you know there's definitely an element
to it where it's like I feel like I need
to be on I feel like I need to entertain
and I don't want to just
be silent if I was being as productive
as possible I would be just silent
especially since I hadn't done this
before
so it's a tough mix
there's some big pillars
foreign
get all these uniformly scaled
something like that
foreign
thing that
this uh this dolly move does
it's called a Hitchcock Zoom
or a dolly Zoom where you're you're
dollying in and zooming out at the same
time
and
you're you're really gonna tell what's
going on if there's stuff in the
foreground there's stuff in the
background for it to actually mess with
so
if I hop into the camera here
I have to adjust my exposure again
because we turn those lights back on
and we go through our move
you can see that things in the
foreground and things in the background
are are really what's getting that that
movement the sense of movement so the
more stuff you have in the foreground in
the background
and the more depth in your scene there
is the more of an effect you'll get with
this camera move so
you know I'm I'm kind of challenging
myself with a smaller scene but I'm
gonna have some stuff scattered around
and whatnot
so I'm not too worried about it but
that's why I'm putting these pillars in
front
we can also take these guys
and move them to the back as well
split the difference somewhere so it's
maybe more along the lines of
a setup
and I want to switch these because
just because
once brighter one's darker
and we can even brighten this up uh alts
alt f
Ctrl F no
um
Ctrl B
or browse
that will find the asset if we double
click the master material we can
just adjust the let's see
Albedo controls the brightness that's
what we want right there
foreign
the back wall all right that back wall
is going to be very very important
because it's going to catch a lot of
light it's going to have a lot of detail
so something like this we can go to town
on that back wall and add a ton of
details on that back wall
but I'm curious as to how much of that
back wall will be seen because
again I want
I should focus on the roof we were
talking about the roof I need to focus
on the roof because this is going to be
the scene
similar to this setup here once we get
into our our final camera position I'm
planning on having a different camera
move that starts further back because
I'm introing the video right so I want
to start further back dolly in close
close until I get into the locked
camera position that y'all have
so I'm going to see a little bit more of
my scene from way back behind
so let's keep focusing on the roof I
don't know how much will be seen of the
actual background
foreign
we get here I think
the scene is pretty locked
let me think about some screens
because I want there to be video screens
that flicker on and display like this
virtual reality that the character is in
so technically they're going to be
surrounded by screens
um which is tough because if they're
surrounded by screens then you don't
really see any of the background and
whatnot
um
so I have to figure out how that's gonna
work now I have this like temp
set up here
temporary screens that'll cover the
character
and I think the floor will probably have
some screens too
which could be pretty sweet I just need
to figure out like
are they in a room of screens or are
they in a warehouse or are they in a
warehouse
in a room of screens in a warehouse yeah
you know what I'm saying
so I have to figure out the blend
between that and how much you're seeing
of the other
the other setup
because it's essentially like a VR room
you know
foreign
box it could be a box with like
no roof and um
could work
so that when you get in with the camera
you've landed in this box but the box is
in the middle of a warehouse I guess
very similar to Mission Impossible
now that I think about it
yeah let me hit shot deck.com really
quick
it's a website where you get to look up
different movie frames and stuff let me
log in
first
all right
hmm
that's weird
Mission Impossible
it wasn't even Mission Impossible five
Rogue Nation
is that it
no
all right we got some super chats done
we saved polar bears what's up
the work goes into these monthly
challenges well that is a that is a
question
a lot of work absolutely a lot of work
um it depends on the person
some people spend five hours on their
render some people spend 200 hours on
their render so it really depends
it's really up to you and and how
ambitious you're trying to be in your
scene I'm trying to do something in the
middle I'm not trying to go too
ambitious
um but I'm trying to do something
pretty cool
uh something that I'm proud of
so yeah I'm right there in the middle
uh we got some others too very nice
drove Luke music probably probably
butchering that apologies your main
reference image is from the music video
Wide Open by The Chemical Brothers yep
done at my company the mill just before
I joined wow
that's awesome yeah that's one of the
best music videos I've ever seen hands
down uh absolute incredible
incredible amount of work in that one
uh and Mark
hi love your work you're a huge
inspiration thank you Mark for the Super
Chat very kind of you
thanks for hanging out with us
got a thousand people up in here good
stuff
the fifth movie was
I see Rogue Nation it was the last one
it was the one we're like
it was the one where he um
was interrogating
that dude in the hospital bed
and then the room like fell open it was
that one
I don't remember
the name I mean I can look it up really
quick let me look this up really quick
his Rogue nation that is the fifth one
why is it six
which one are they on at this point I
don't even know
Fallout that's the one I'm talking about
all right
yes
yeah it's this scene right here
where like he's in the hospital room
with him right
and then the room Falls open to reveal
this
I guess I'm going for something very
similar
so I'm gonna save this
boom
drag it into my prf document
and take a look so
yeah there's like the scaffolding up
here
um it's clearly like a film set
and it's this open room inside of a
bigger room so I guess that's literally
what I'm trying to do
okay all right that's a good that's a
good reference
it's a very good reference in terms of
like physical space and what's going on
nice okay
shot deck yeah it's a good service
this is a very good service
so I feel like these pillars wouldn't be
in here it definitely wouldn't be in
here
and the room might be a little smaller
too
trying to think because this is our
final
final pose what we could do is make the
SE guys like
the aspect ratio of our actual scene
which is one by two three seven which is
movie widescreen which that basically is
right there
foreign
okay
this room would be big too this would be
a big
pretty big room this is cool though I
like this this Vibe it's a Cool vibe I
think this setup can work
again the idea is to justify all these
other renders that are going to be
happening in the challenge
by making kind of like a VR room
and everything spawns from these these
these like screens right here will
flicker I'm gonna make an another
environment and these screens will
flicker
and light this character
in the environment and it'll kind of
seamlessly blend into the actual
environment and then it'll go into the
renders so that's that's the idea
cool
I think we can probably do like every
other
one here
holding alt duplicate
foreign
[Music]
sweet
[Music]
and we can open this room up even larger
if we need to
but we're starting to get the vibe here
so come from here
the Montage will start
and then we'll kind of Dolly in
until we're in into this little room
here and I can take this floor piece as
well I think and bring this up
to have a ceiling as well
yeah super cool obviously you can see
why I'm using 2001
as a reference because it's a it's a
similar setup no doubt
this looks cool
um
yeah this is gonna be awesome
this character will be all connected up
to
machinery and stuff
ghost in the show Vibes for sure
soulcypher can a beginner win
I'd say there's a chance
um
I think
so far
well yeah that's a tough one can a
beginner win anything could excuse me
anything can happen all right I'll say
that much anything can happen
um
obviously the more experience you have
the better you're gonna be
which is why we do these weekly
challenges on my Discord server to get
people prepped up to I've heard this so
many times and it's so cool that like
people have done the weekly challenges
on my Discord server and they are
prepped now for these challenges which
is great that's that's the best thing
ever
um because yeah they're a little
intimidating that's that's a fact
but if you don't Dive In
like when how are you gonna get better
so I wouldn't I wouldn't like focus on
winning this thing
too hard especially if you're just
starting
I would focus more on like where are you
at with your skill level and can you
raise the bar for yourself just a little
bit can you step up to the next level
I think that's a great goal to have
okay
let's see if we can't get some like
I just want to block this in all right
so I don't want to go too crazy with it
but
this kind of scaffolding up here
let's see if we can't get that going
um because I think that's a big part of
the
the gak as you call it
um up above this thing a bunch of gak
gak is like
wires cables pipes
uh carts it's all the stuff on the film
set that
um is not not to be seen it should not
be in the final image
if you turn the camera 180 and you see
the crew and you see the cameras and the
carts and the cables that's all the gak
you know so
that's going to be the detail of this
scene here for me is all the Gak
and that's going to be up here this uh
I I almost want to call it truffling
I'm gonna call it truffling let's work
on our truffling today
um
so what we can do I can actually make a
new level and just call this uh basic
we'll save this file save as
under
levels
and this will just be called
mm stands for moving meditations in this
case and I want to make
a project where I can just build assets
and stuff
um and they'll just be called assets
and let's make one of these trufflings
cylinder
we can bring a character in
the stand-in character
under let's see where are you under mesh
that way we know
what scale we're dealing with
and I'm just going to make one piece of
this and then duplicate it
I'm gonna turn on snapping
what is that
uh we went out
one two three four
five
let's go up one two three four five
and let's duplicate these
down
I'm using that
um
I'm using this as reference here
looking at this
I'm sure there's assets you can get on
the on the store
but I'm doing it this way
for now
all right and then let's see
it kind of
turn into a little X
we can change this let's see to every
five degrees so we can go 45 degrees
what
I did the wrong one
just this one
um
just like that
we'll take these guys and
push them back a little bit
and I think okay besides
getting this over here
holding alt to duplicate
we just need it on
bottom part two we'll go 90 degrees
about like that
and then we'll go again
90 degrees there
and 90 degrees here
finally these guys here and here
um
those in
and then this is what we'll duplicate so
I'm gonna group all this
Ctrl G to group
I'll pop that into a folder called
scaffolding
and ALT
drag these out
and instead of duplicating the folder a
bunch I'm actually just going to
duplicate
stuff here
cool
that should be enough for what we need
so I'm gonna just grab the scaffolding
folder
and we are going to copy it we're going
to open up our scene here
and we'll paste it
ah it just grabbed the folder
let's open the assets level again
grab all that stuff
copy it
paste it
awesome
I'm gonna get rid of the site
and let's group this uh let's group this
scaffolding
it looks like that is the case sweet
[Music]
yo I just thought of another good
reference too
um let's see Ian Hubert
Dynam of dream
literally the first shot
very simple
Warehouse
boom grab that
paste it
into purif
and we got ourselves another reference
if you grab all this stuff you can hit
uh Ctrl alt up arrow and it'll equalize
all the frame sizes and control P will
automatically
kind of like group them together and
organize them but this is a good
reference for just a
very very simple he's got that roof down
his roof is solid or sorry his ceiling
is solid
um and it's just a big old room
with literally like there's no detail on
these pillars
it's all about the lighting see here's
what I mean about like
the lights that
are bright in some areas dim in the
other like
he's even doing it here
up in the corners
and there's there's texture to these
lights they're not just white they have
a fall off to them which is really nice
so I'll definitely be using that as
inspiration too
all right so the scaffolding the
scaffolding
we're seeing scaffolding here as well
it's just a little different
and here
and let's go ahead and give this some
material
I'ma hop into my master materials
let's actually just take one of these
basic material instances I will
duplicate it
and I'll just call this uh
Chrome
I wish there was an easier way to do
this
foreign
materials I'll drop this chrome material
boom on all of them
and we'll open it up to adjust it to go
with a chrome look you want
one in the metallic roughness we can do
like 0.2 specular needs to be one base
color I believe should be black
I lied White
um but you can dim it as you get closer
to Black
and I think that look is a little bit
better
um and then we can drop that yeah boom
onto here but it's looking a little
intense so instead of looking at this
ball I'm going to look at the actual
scaffolding itself it's a it's pretty
chromed out so I'm gonna
take the roughness up to maybe 0.5
Drop the Base color maybe a little bit
more
foreign roughness yeah that's looking
cool
so if you were to really
set up
some some freaking e-walls
then I would definitely want to make
sure they don't fall down
and having some scaffolding
in the mix is probably a good idea
so I would do something like this
duplicate it over to the other side
oh
so many pieces
all the way over there what the heck
foreign
so annoying
there's an easier way
I just want to regroup this stuff man
come on
that's why you really gotta make sure
that um
you're organized
easy Sonics that would be great I would
love to make it one piece so why don't I
select one box with all cylinders
make it as a static mesh
one box with all cylinders one box you
mean one folder
that's a little a little out of hand
here
foreign
so that's that
uh
these guys in the middle let's see if I
just
don't know
135 to 214.
foreign
all right
see this is the stuff that's not fun
right
asset organization all that good stuff
let's get our ceiling beams
organized
all right pop those into a folder
[Music]
fluorescent
what is in fluorescent fluorescent light
all right these are our fluorescent
lights
they're both the same thing okay
foreign
let's get all these lamps in a folder
uh housing fluorescent housing
and then the actual light bulbs
themselves
all of these
with those in another folder
call them bulbs
but there's our fluorescent light
so that goes under lighting interior
lights
and these are uh room light
okay
we have the room itself
[Music]
we have some scaffolding we have some
screens all right so inside of the room
see we need a geometry folder
which we can put the room in here the
scaffolding the screens
we have a plastic chair let's try and
get that other chair the mega scans
chair in here I'm really glad I'm doing
this I I think I finally figured out
what my scene looks like now so I'm very
happy about that I was a little hesitant
before I didn't quite know what it was
gonna be before this
so I'm glad to finally have figured it
out and and really find that uh
Mission Impossible reference this is it
it's basically
like this setup here but with video
screens
inside of a warehouse
something like this
something like this
something like this so I'm feeling
pretty good about that
feeling pretty good about that
but I'm gonna go for as long as I can
today y'all
I'm gonna go for as long as I can
because I need to get work done on this
thing how's everyone doing
you guys doing all right
following along doing some art yourself
ah
um so if y'all are just popping in or
hanging around we do have that stream
exclusive kit bash code you can save 20
off on anything you want on kitbash.com
we'll be doing these exclusive discounts
throughout these challenge streams
so definitely check that out I feel like
trying to if you were thinking about
getting some batch stuff anyway
um
yeah this has been this is I mean I'm
saying like I'm wrapping up
I'm just taking a little break at this
moment because
I need to keep going I'm glad I finally
figured out where I'm going what I'm
doing
[Music]
um
which is the hardest part figuring out
what you the heck you're gonna do
uh so we got there reference is key is
it's huge it's guiding my process
through this stream as you guys are
seeing
very very helpful
and I'll get into the details later
and just keep working throughout the
week and hopefully next week when I come
back next week
I'll have a
hopefully animated character with all
the stuff on them
that's my goal that is my goal that
would be the hardest part for me I know
how to place Essence I know how to light
things
what I don't know how to do is
create a character find a character
I'm going to figure out how to put them
onto
this mocap data which there's tutorials
out there there's one on the server on
the Discord server if you want to figure
out how to do it in both blender or an
Unreal Engine
there's tutorials for both
on the Discord server
um in the moving meditations
uh what is it FAQs and tips
Channel or category rather
or Channel whatever I get confused this
chord is confusing sometimes
um
so I also need to figure out how to do
Dynamic cables and stuff hanging from
this character's head down to the ground
and I'm probably gonna simulate all that
inside of c4d and Export an Olympic of
some sort
and bring that into Unreal Engine
that way my simulation looks really nice
I'll probably do some cloth as well in
c4d
we'll see if I have that cloth figured
out I'm just going to try and get a
version First of an animated character
with some something on their head some
sort of VR sci-fi thing
with like all the wires hanging down
I'll go for that first
um
yeah so much work to be done we're one
weekend out of the four weeks
and my goal is to have
a version done pretty much by
pretty much by the next stream
I would very much like that
a lot of the detail work is going to be
in adding decals and whatnot
to my walls to my background it's how
I'm gonna get things like
foreign
like this like these stains here on the
wall
all these pock marks
this bottom layer here of grunge this
black that's those are going to be
decals
all that stuff's gonna be decals
um
what's another example of a decal
basically all the all the damage all the
imperfections will be decals
there's gonna be a lot of detail in
these pipes here too that I'm gonna have
to get right
but let's keep going
let us
keep going
spinosy video
what's up yo
you say love you man keep doing what
you're doing finally going to be able to
participate yes yes that is what I love
to hear
there's good news
people participate in these challenges
for the first time
heck yeah
good stuff man thank you for that Super
Chat
oh let's get those let's get the mega
scans 3D assets going let's see what we
got
so we got our concrete pillars
we got our fluorescent ceiling lamp
we have some modular pipes to work with
there's a lot of stuff we didn't
actually bring over so let me hop back
in and
bring some things over we had this chair
we have these pipes
so I probably could have made
um let's see let's see yeah let's bring
this over
oh no
I don't want highest quality I want
nanite
oh I'll actually let me let me let me go
back in there and
ceiling beam ceiling beam pillar pillar
pillar metal chair
let's delete this metal chair
and then
those pipes
I guess I guess the pipes didn't come in
which is good news
so I want
all these guys as nanite quality
Oh weird
huh
and it's not even an option okay so it
is for the chair
let's bring that in
but these metal poles
we can do medium quality even
and then there was like
some metal scaffolding that I wanted to
bring in as well
the port beams metal support beams
these ones
the rusty pillars
awesome
foreign
and have it so it's not two two pieces
let's just have it be one piece
and same deal for the ceiling
I don't think there's a reason to have
it be six pieces
I'm just cleaning up right now
Samira you're very welcome enjoy your
evening thanks for hanging out with us
see you soon
alright so I have my
infinite concrete materials they're on
my gum Road you all can grab them if you
want the link is in the description to
my gum Road
see if we can't use them here this is
exactly what I made them for was for
like large scale
situations
um
so let's start with long wall one and
see how long this wall really is
all right
I think the long wall one is too long
for
all right here we go
so this just needs to be tiled and
adjusted let me
get rid of these guys
and I don't want to stretch these walls
because I don't want to have to counter
stretch them I would I would certainly
have to do that
so I'm just scaling them up large
sweet
I don't know if that is the right
material let's try long wall three
this one could work
on wall four is insane
I have to scale that down a lot
all right
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
sweet that looks good oh God dang it
foreign
I wonder let's see if this one will look
good here
that's pretty cool
the back wall I'd probably have to make
a new material new instance
that back wall but I think for now it's
okay I'm not trying to get it perfect
hmm
foreign
pull over 1.6 gigs all right
Maja yes this will be available to watch
after the live stream
foreign
nice I can take this floor and
if I rotate it 90 degrees
that's pretty cool
foreign
I don't I don't remember how to fix the
texture streaming pool thing
um
it is in one of my last streams though
it's in the Stream with like the uh
the sewer
it's like the last Unreal Engine stream
I did in the sewer and I think there
it's lit it's it's marked in the time
code where it's called like Pro tip or
something
if anyone knows okay I believe it should
be console command r dot streaming pool
size zero
r dot streaming
dot pool size
zero
all right we'll see if that works
so with these uh materials I made
they actually come with a dry and a wet
version
of the texture so you can get this nice
like wet floor look
all right let's find that with control B
we can darken these actually I'm gonna
probably darken the floor
foreign
let's do
brightness
like 0.5 or something
yeah and these walls too I feel like can
be
darken two what I'm doing is I'm
clicking the wall itself I hit Ctrl B to
browse for the asset it's actually I
don't even need a browse I just click
the asset and on the bottom right here
where my head is blocking
we can move that over yeah thanks Soto
um you can click this little find folder
button and that'll take you to the
material that that it's uh that it has
applied to itself you can open that up
and I have this on the other screen this
is my material instance I've set this up
so I can adjust brightness intensity
roughness all that good stuff
and I'll take it down to like
0.75 they look a little blue to me as
well
could be the colorblind but I threw a
tint on there
so we can take that tint somewhere
towards the orange
side of life
in for the ground
I will tint it as well
Just a Touch
then we can darken up these pillars
but again I'm I'm falling into
[Music]
the detail that that doesn't really need
detail at this moment in time
falling into that trap I can't do that
I need to work as broadly as possible
and then get detailed
but I'm digging this it's looking pretty
cool
um
the walls maybe the walls could be more
of a brick
like this
I guess we're not really seeing the
walls there these are painted brick yep
plaster yeah I feel like concrete
probably isn't the move for
the walls
I think brick would add a nice bit of
detail to that so let's see what quixel
has shall we
clay don't give up my friend
there are tutorials on the Discord
server
talking about your exact problem in the
rules tips and FAQs
Channel
so don't
give up quite yet my friend
all right we're looking for Brick
like this
painted brick
perfect
highest quality is going to be 8K but
let's go with high quality at 4K for now
[Music]
I'm just worried you're really gonna see
the tiling and that's why I made these
concrete textures called that's why
they're called endless concrete is
because
you don't see the tiling
I got stuff 100K pixels
out into the distance so like there's
50k 100K 25k
um they go out there so
that's the only thing I'm worried about
these surfaces here but let's try it
painted brick wall
yeah I already see the tiling
and I'm gonna have to hide that with a
ton of
individual little decals that's gonna
take forever but
let's see how this feels
we will adjust the tiling
probably one of the tile three times
yeah the scale feels right but obviously
it's tiling right so
that's the tricky part
that is certainly the tricky part
you could
duplicate the material
and mix between a larger one and a
smaller one but it's tough because
bricks are all the same size right
you could do a clean version and then go
in and add these scratched up bricks
with decals but that's a whole bunch of
work as well
I'm sure there's there's got to be
something
got to be some sort of honestly I could
scan a brick wall I could photo scan a
brick wall and put it in place there
that could be a good move
but let's see what else
quixel has
go to services
we got brick and we can actually search
by size
so I believe oh wait you can't search my
size uh can you
yes here we go all right so this little
uh up at the top right here
it's inverted pyramid you can go all
sizes and look for eight meters there
are no brick textures that are eight
meters but four by eight perhaps
they have some of those okay
rough brick wall plastered brick floor
let's try plastered brick floor let's
favorite that
um
let's go with this standard brick wall
favorite that we can turn it white
I'll grab both oh let's let's see what
else we have two to four meters two to
four meters is probably what we were
dealing with
and we're really gonna see these guys
tile yeah there's the one that we had
but you're just gonna see the tiling on
these guys
this one may not be bad it's pretty
uniform
which is kind of what we want
and then we can spice it up later but
let's download high quality we I don't
think we need 8K
oh this one's great
this one's great
it's gonna tile like no one's business
though
because the more detail it has
the more uniqueness it has like a big
old hole in the wall you're really gonna
see that tile
but we'll see what we can do
and we'll probably just have to be
hiding a bunch of stuff
half timbered wall let's try let's try
this let's see what this looks like that
could be fun
oh damaged plaster ball that's a good
one too
foreign
so there's no shortage of two to four
meter sized brick walls here on qixel we
need the larger ones though so
let's also look at concrete floors
we can mess with that as well and find a
floor that looks good
um
ground
forestry's jungle no surfaces
concrete
damaged
yes
and then we'll search for flooring here
and we'll see if they have any large
size four to eight meters
wow that one's interesting I'm gonna
just try that because it looks crazy
worn concrete oh that's a nice one
foreign
so you see the less detail is uh there
is the less it'll look like it's tiling
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
you can see the tiling in it a little
bit but you can hide it with some
some decals
um
let's keep moving
I don't like that look
[Music]
I don't like that look
yeah not really a fan
cracked concrete floor
pretty cool again
not gonna lie damage wall plaster
yeah tiling on that one's pretty intense
this one will be interesting
it looks pretty cool
ah man so tough
that's interesting though
[Music]
that's the one we tried
worn concrete I think this was for the
floor
I like that other one better
this one here
or even
my texture
that looked pretty darn good
one of these two
foreign
we also have some
other acids to test out let's see 3D
assets
it was those uh those beams
these Rusty pillars
instead of our concrete
guys
so many options when it comes to 3D
let's flip that bring it on up
wow what are the odds of that connecting
nearly perfectly it's pretty crazy
you can also combo these too like
something like that
because they are doing it here
let's see
well I guess it's the pillar and then
the pipe next to it
and then you have it here you have like
this random pillar here which definitely
feels out of place but it's obviously
there
pretty sweet
but it feels like more of a pipe
situation could be here
the heck
weird
so why are these off-center what the
heck
foreign
let's see if we can't talk about decals
I'm trying to hit all the angles
um
for y'all
so if we do
see
decals bam
and there should be some like grunge
stuff like leakage perhaps
we want something that we can really
stretch out
like this here actually this leakage
might be perfect
so I'm gonna bring over the high quality
version let's download this
and we'll add it
and this is really going to help with
the floor
let's bring this out right we can see
this on the floor here right
and it's really cool the way it works
it's a volume and it's projected on
whatever
you know whatever object it's
overlapping right so
I'm gonna bring this over to the wall
and let's go ahead and rotate it up
90 degrees
and move it up
something like this okay
and we're going to want to scale this
down
and we're gonna have to figure out a way
for it to not like go over the floor
like it is right there
so I wonder if we can like scrunch this
in
foreign
close
we want it to be right
right down there
there we go
it's super thin but that's exactly what
we want
and we can take this hopefully and um
stretch it out
and duplicate it
foreign
yes I want this
bam
that adds so much
look it's in the reference y'all
it's in the reference
right
the answers come from the reference so
if we go up into this material
we can drop its brightness as well
so that's going to be our Albedo
controls
wait I lied hold on
Albedo intensity veto intensity
[Music]
color overlay color overlay that's what
we want we just want it to be black
there you go I think it's a little much
it's a little too dark
[Music]
um
so we just take that overlay intensity
slider
to zero and then just work it up like
0.5
Maybe
and we can probably drop the scale of
these two
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
just like that I'm going to bring these
over to the other side
and you know what before I do that
actually
I'm going to alt drag it out duplicate
it
I'm going to flatten it on the ground
and have it be
here as well
for whatever reason it's reacting in
very interestingly here
but we'll get there
so I might have to let's see duplicate
this thing
and pop this new material
onto these two
turn off
that color overlay
[Music]
interesting okay that's not
doing much for us
but that is that is a bug of some sort
I don't know what but
hmm
I wonder if it has to do with
my material maybe because this is my
material
as opposed to a mega scans material
so I wonder if I put a new Surface on it
no okay that's good to know
foreign
let's just
find it Ctrl B
search for it
foreign
and now it's working properly we just
reset it
[Music]
oh it's because it was too scrunched
but we opened it up I don't know it's
working now that's all that matters
foreign
there we go
people in the chat were saying that it
was upside down maybe that's it
oh y'all are saying it's upside down
maybe
hey you're right
thank you guys
always learning something new from you
guys thank you so much
boom all right so now with that
we can copy this over to the other side
alt drag
why'd I go up like that
the heck
oh no it's on the ground now okay
and we're gonna uh do a big old 180
and slide it on down
awesome
so that's decals all right
um
and I'm going to decal up this entire
place
so a lot of work a lot of time it's
gonna be spent
working on them decals on those details
all right let's see what our camera
looks like but I guess our camera is
only going to be
in this like little close-up area here
um
I'm gonna duplicate the camera
and we'll get up in there let's see we
don't need both of these on here
goodness
come on now
there's a bug where I change my layout
and I can't pilot the camera so I have
to actually go to it hit G to reveal it
and then I can
can find it
foreign
let's take this camera back
and I'm going to open up that focal
length
so it feels the the
this room feels a little narrow
so I would probably
do a little something to open it up just
a touch but
get I can get there
I also have these like
post-process materials
that I can use I'll show you how it
works really quick
materials post-process materials so I
followed a tutorial on how to do this
one
and it's basically making a camera
Distortion material
right that uses the screen position
and a radial gradient
pipe into a missive color
and that will allow you actually if you
have a post-process volume
if you go down to
post process let's see where is it where
is it post-process materials under right
under render features
you can add
a post-process material
and it'll actually
allow me to get some of that camera
distortion
that you're seeing
um I mean you know Ian Huber does it a
lot you can see that bend there
um and it's what happens with an actual
camera
this one is very subtle here
very very subtle usually you try and
like
correct for those things when you're
actually filming something
but you can see it
um
yeah even here Chris Nolan boom right
you see that bend
on both sides it bulges out it's very
subtle
you can see it really well on the on the
ceiling Maybe
on the ceiling up here
yeah
yeah it's all these little subtle camera
um things that usually you want to edit
out but with 3D we want to edit it in
um Ian goes goes heavy with it I know
some of y'all go heavy with it but
it's one of those things where like
you gotta go to the point where you
barely you just don't notice it so this
is too much
this is far too much
this
might be the most I'd go
and God
0.075 is what I meant
this might be looking nice
foreign
we got a super chat up here
what's up
spinos C video
thanks again for that Super Chat uh do
you animate things like cars driving
cloth Sims Etc and C40 then import them
into ue5 yes that is what I will be
doing
um I'm gonna do my like clock simulation
inside of c4d I'm gonna do my like cable
simulation in c4d
and then export that as an Olympic into
unreal
and that's the way to go baby
at least for me you know
easy Sonics is there a way to share the
tutorial for the Distortion material
I don't remember it but let me try
looking
really quick for you
let's see camera
the lens distortion
distortion
Unreal Engine five
tutorial
yeah this is it
it doesn't work with
it does not work with pngs
but
here we go
let me paste this for you guys boom
that is the lens Distortion tutorial
ue4 but it works in ue5 as you can see
here
um it doesn't work with PNG exports I'm
not sure if it works with
exr exports but I know it works with
jpeg exports so you'll have to
experiment with that it'll just give you
a black screen
yeah but I really feel like
I really feel like this
set up
needs a bigger room
honestly
so I'm gonna move this stuff out
even further
foreign
settings again
foreign
I don't care about I'll just stretch it
the reason I'm not stretching the other
walls I said it before but I don't want
to have to like unstretch it with the
materials
it's just annoying oh I forgot about the
ceiling we have an actual ceiling
I got excited I love texturing
it'd be cool to go for that like uh
I almost want to say foil it's not foil
but it's um
[Music]
like insulation material
oh and this this wall this back wall can
get pushed back even
that feels better
yep that feels a bit more vast
cool
foreign
Batman Lair almost
yeah let me just work our lighting so we
have this uh these screens which are
just emissives
materials uh
basic is it this one
let's see
whoa
that's crazy
that's pretty cool
we should definitely lock our exposure
too here in uh
the post process volume so that way what
we're seeing is actually what our camera
is seeing
so we'll go exposure
metering mode
manual and I think that was 12.
[Music]
these lights too
these lights gonna get turned up
[Music]
there we go
foreign
take this camera turn it up a little bit
a little underexposed
12. why is 12 here different from
12 here
interesting I don't know why
foreign
it is different
maybe it's like one stop off for some
reason
sweet yeah so this is when we get in to
our camera angle and since I'm starting
the Montage I'm going to start it out
here
let's get a bit a little depth of field
so
I'll probably raise this up too
something like that yeah
[Music]
all right
um and then depth of field yes depth of
field this is starting to turn into
something y'all I'm I'm
getting happy with this I think it's a
little too front lip let me get the
depth of field and then
we'll get that front light out of there
all right after the track we want to
track this mannequin for now okay so
I'll click on that mannequin oh actually
no no sorry
undo
we don't want to track them we we want
the
um
because we want the camera position
to do our own thing right
it's the
where is it the focus settings we can
set that to tracking Focus settings
tracking
tracking Focus settings
and we'll eye drop the mannequin then
we can change our f-stop to like
2.8
ah so this is reacting like an actual
camera
because when I let in more
exposure
from the camera I'll show you
so with this camera here
if I were to you see how the background
is all blurry and stuff
right blur your background
shallower depth of field
more light you're literally opening the
iris up to allow more light in
but if you squint your eyeballs you can
actually do this with your eyes if you
like look at your hands like this and
you squint
your the background
fingers will be more in focus
if you open your eyes fully they're
going to be less in Focus so if I were
to bring my everyone did their hand
thing I'm sure I'm 100 sure I did it
let's see I don't want to mess this up
all right
[Music]
okay
that's shutter speed
which also controls how bright things
are
but the f-stop here in front
notice as I crank this down
the background gets more in focus
right if I turn up the iso to compensate
you can see the background is now more
in focus
but this is what just happened to me and
unreal I took it from an F aperture of
nine
to a 2.8
and it made things bright
so then I gotta
turn my ISO back down
so that's how cameras work
and that's how our camera is working in
Unreal Engine right now kind of don't
like that so I want to switch it back
and let's figure out how to do it
okay
but I want to take that down instead of
2.8 let's take it to like 1.2
which makes it even worse right
so let's go to our
exposure settings
foreign that's kind of why like
um that's why I like doing brightness
instead of this
method I think
I set it to histogram
that's Auto so obviously that's blowing
out like crazy that goes to auto
basic
looks like it's Auto as well
if I set it to manual
I can bring this up
something like this
okay
heck yeah all right
so what we can do now
is if I hop out of this camera
and I'm doing this through the sequencer
so I have my cameras in my sequencer and
I can just click on these to go back and
forth or out to go back to my normal
default view
I'm gonna give myself just a little bit
more room
spacebar to cycle between your gizmos
and
just giving myself a little bit more
room to work with
oh
awesome so these lights in the
foreground are a little much
so what I can do is actually just
select these ones and get rid of them
and maybe before I blank it just get rid
of them
I will
turn them off
see what it looks like
yeah much better
much better
the scene is way more focused on
what's important
and I'll mess with the lighting like I'm
going to come back and tweak the
lighting we're again we're just trying
to get to that 80 Mark I'm trying to get
something usable
as quick as possible
all right
finder sequencer again
yeah it's a little dark on the edges now
but
we you know we can get in there
and tweak all day
yeah that looks awesome
forgot our our uh our grime
our Grime is lost here gotta get it back
and for this I want to be able to see
right so I'm going to go to lit and
uncheck game settings
and crank the EV here
right and we'll just line this up again
sweet
and I don't think we're releasing beyond
that so
I think we're good
dang that was perfect
my post-process volume get out I don't
need to see it
yes
beautiful it's all about this ground
right here
uh this ground it being wet
adds so much
so let's let's find it
by clicking the asset making sure we're
not searching for anything we'll find
the material and we'll search for it
let's open this up
and let's go ahead and
shrink it down so point I'm at point
five let's try 0.35
oh no I lied
I'm scaling it up let's go 0.75
.
you can see the tiling
or wait can you I can't even tell
never mind I don't think you can
um
well offset the Y
yeah that looks sweet
come on now
there we go now
um of course we're gonna mess with the
roughness
if you want to make it look not as wet
or
untoggle the specular wet
and the specular and the roughness wet
and this is kind of what we get but it
looks better
with like the puddle maps in there
I'ma toggle those on
and maybe just take my roughness
intensity
down a bit take my specular intensity
down a bit
and this is all the fine tune this is
just fine-tuned City
this is no reflection at all looks like
a carpet disgusting
but even a little bit that's 0.1
specular 0.1
I like me
a good bit of it
I think that looks great
there's gonna be cables and carts kind
of all around here
I'll mess with the lighting
I think we need a little bit more light
out to the sides of the room
foreign
these are our two looks
right here I was looking in the wrong
view this is I mean I can make it
whatever I want honestly so we can you
know we can push it back a little bit
more
we want to like start it here
I'm feeling like it'll start like way
out here you know
and it'll like as the
the intro starts and I have the text on
screen that says like you know all the
artists
how many submissions and it's doing a
slow dolly in and it's probably blurred
out probably be something like
let's see if we set
the focus settings to
to manual
and we took
Focus plane like
really close
or really I would just slide this thing
all the way up
so you can actually see the focus plane
and move it forward and back
and it's cool because it actually
interacts with your environment but I'd
bring it like
all the way close essentially
and it would start like this
as we dolly in
and as we get closer and closer and
closer and closer
you know you would start to
eventually get to this point where it's
in focus
everything starts to come into Focus
this can be awesome
but for now
we can keep tracking that mannequin
ah
time is it how long we've been going
212.
I can go a little bit more
go a little bit more
because I'm really enjoying myself today
this is a good
this is a good stream
foreign
have to get detailed here with these
pillars but
as the idea they'll go out to the side
there oh the ceiling yeah let's get that
um
let's get that freaking what should we
call it
um
easy Sonics
I ain't ignoring super chats
buddy not on purpose
I feel like I've hit every single one
would you talk about Sun
calling me out like that not even true
did I miss did I miss a Super Chat
y'all y'all
must have been way back
you gotta be scrounging through these
chats here
I see you easy Sonics I see ya
am I gonna stream my work in c4d as well
um I'm gonna stream depending what I'm
doing on the day how far I've gotten
I will stream my work in whatever
program I'm in at the time it just
happens to be all unreal at this time
once I get through my streams I'm gonna
do four streams
and hopefully by the fourth stream I'm
like done and I'm just in DaVinci or
after effects
tweaking color correction and all that
good stuff
and then we have the Judgment Day stream
we got the montages
um and then we have the winner stream
but also coming down the pipe the pipe
or the pike I think it's the pike coming
down the pike we got um
my art breakdown I'm gonna break down
all of this my whole process on what I'm
doing here
um and what I will be doing in a very
bite-sized probably 20 minute video
um because I don't expect everyone to go
through all these streams especially
since they're not like the last streams
I've done where I finished the art
before the stream and I just shotgun
blast y'all through the entire process
in like an hour and a half to two
this is way more me just experimenting
and figuring things out on the fly like
you're seeing me do right here
which I think is cool
I think it's fun
all right let's get the ceiling the
roofing
so let's hop into that qixel bridge
see you later Julio thanks for stopping
by
I'll probably get the ceiling done we
can call it
at least the material on the ceiling so
let's look for surfaces
and ah what would this even be Roofing
or sealing
um
I know the exact
like material
that I'm going for uh it's a chrome
material
and it's kind of crinkly
maybe this tarp I might just grab this
tarp
let's bring it over
and see what we can do this might be a
thing that I actually
simulate in c4d like a cloth Sim and
droop it down so they're all kind of
bubbly
let's go and add this
make a scan surface
tarp sweet okay
put this tarp on the ceiling
all right
so let's adjust this a little bit shall
we
tiling
two and two
maybe three and three perhaps
doesn't look bad
and then what I'm gonna do
is actually
make it metallic
so metallic override base metallic will
set to one
I actually don't need the Albedo
hmm
how am I gonna do this
italic is set to one our specular should
be set to one
our roughness should be set to like
point two
that's close
kind of hard to see
um maybe
metallic isn't coming through
let's get our brightness up
Eric yo what's up
you never got that scan of Nick's head
all good though lots of love from your
Maniac Rico
yeah
yeah
I thought uh I didn't want to ask Nick
just photo scan his head and give it to
some dude on the internet so
but I appreciate the Super Chat very
much
um and and for the love and the support
I just don't think Nick's head Nick's 3D
head is yours for the taking
so I appreciate your understanding
uh let's get
all of these
cylinders
in place Ctrl shift G will regroup them
and let's go ahead and bring it over to
their side
and we'll duplicate it again
have it be on top
foreign
a couple more times over
I wish there was an easy way to select
stuff in unreal
I really do I also wish there was an
easy way to duplicate things in unreal
all right
foreign
foreign
yeah that's pretty sweet
um
grab all these
bring them back
I wish there was an easy your way
foreign
yeah that doesn't look good
I will fix it later
I say
we'll fix it in post
absolutely
thank you
default
I needed snapping in my life
where it was snapping when I needed it
sweet
let's get these guys drug out
come on it's because of this uh
this camera distortion
it's not it's not actually letting me
click what I'm trying to click
I'm being fooled
let's see
materials post-process material lens
Distortion instance
I'll just take it from 0.075 to zero
there we go
foreign
foreign
are some actual lights in here
foreign
yeah
because emissives like
I feel like they don't do the best job
at lighting your scene
it's going to look a lot better A lot
cleaner with these
all right now let's scale them up proper
foreign
what's going on congrats on the million
subs thank you very much
uh you've come a long way since the
Freddie W days oh my goodness yes I have
it has been a long time since then
Freddy W days those were the beginning
the beginning days and it's been awesome
seeing your growth Through The Years
keep at it thank you so much thank you
for the support thanks for stopping by
and hanging out with us
making some 3D art together man it's
gonna be awesome
yeah I really appreciate that man Freddy
let me uh man Freddy
Freddy is quite the guy
um
he Not only was the person
to invite me out to LA
and do VFX with him and film cool videos
with him
he allowed me to pay really cheap rent
um he is the one who kind of
reintroduced me and my wife
now my wife
um
and convince me to like follow up with
her and like
because I was a very shy person let me
tell you that I was a very very shy man
with the ladies
and Freddie Freddie was like the person
I needed who was like dude what are you
doing you're crazy
she likes you
talk to her
that's what I needed to hear
I was a terrified young little man back
in those days
so he did that
virtual Shadow map page pool overflow
detected
interesting
I have no idea what that means
what else did Freddie do I mean he gave
me a job
I learned so much from him
as well as from samaniko
yeah lots of lots of good people in my
life I cannot
complain
I definitely would not be where I am
today if it weren't for those guys
all right so let's look at the
difference
these are
our uh
light box lights
and let's put them in I guess we'll put
them in screens because
technically go in screens
and let's
hmm
hop into this View
let's turn off those lights and see what
happens
so immediately we're seeing a lot more
detail
in our character and on this chair
right we can actually see what's going
on now
and I can't wait because once I build
out my 3D environment the one on the
rooftops
right
this one once I build this out
and we dolly in to this shot here
these screens are gonna flicker on
all across
and the character will now be in this
environment
and then now when it cuts to all the
other renders
everyone's gonna know it's just a
character in this landscape and it's
like
going on this VR Adventure I guess
kind of what I'm getting at so I think
it's a cool idea I wanted to do
something that
Justified all the other renders in this
montage
so guys I think uh it's time for me to
get some food here
before I leave before you guys go
um I want to talk about a couple things
just for like announcements and news and
whatnot so
um the Discord server if you're not in
the Discord server at this point
definitely do so because that's where
all of the rules and FAQs and and things
go on for this challenge that's where
they're at
um
you don't want to miss these like stage
they're like Town Hall meetings that we
have
um and we do them every Monday
at
time to be doing that Soto
11 o'clock
11 A.M PST I think that's the last time
we we did it last time it'll be in the
Discord server it'll be in the events so
don't miss that another time for for you
in Spain I know at the time but I don't
know if that's helpful I'm gonna send
the link they'll just click again and
it'll tell you guys the time and that
way you also change the Subscribe if you
haven't
yeah so we we like get your guys's
feedback we look at your art when we
look into your art and your progress how
you're coming along in the challenge
next Monday this upcoming Monday
um and talking to you about any of the
problems that you're going through and
you know we'll just bring people up and
we'll have a good chat with the
community
um what else what else
um
yeah I'll be back next Saturday
hopefully way further along in this
scene kind of walk you through what I've
done and keep cranking at it
um the kit bash kit bash exclusive
discount code it's up in the description
or in the description it's pinned in the
chat right at the moment
um there's only 50 codes so if you guys
want to hop in there and
and uh get yourself 20 off on anything
on kipash
um they're doing these exclusively for
these streams for this challenge it's
pretty sweet
um and their assets are definitely going
to help me create my rooftop scene when
the time comes
um anything else Soto can you think of
anything Soto
um
I don't know thank you for watching
that's about it huh
yeah
guys thank you so much thanks for
hanging out with me uh it's been a good
time
I'm gonna get some food
and then I'll probably keep doing some
VFX
but I'll see you guys soon
keep learning keep growing keep creating
and have fun with this challenge all
right
I will see y'all next week peace out
later
[Music]
foreign
[Music]